[Applause]
it's a moment that's been over a decade
in the making
Pakistan celebrate their first test
victory on home soil since the return of
crickets longest format to the country
earlier this month
countries had avoided plane tests in
Pakistan since the 2009 attack on Sri
Lanka's team bus in Lahore and it was
against Sri Lanka that Pakistan's
landmark victory came the home site only
needed three wickets in Karachi on the
final day to seal victory and they got
the first one with the opening sort of
the morning
the remaining batsmen fell soon after
Pakistan taken just 15 minutes to get
the job done Nasim Shah was the hero the
16 year old stepping up with five
wickets in the final innings to not only
seal a 263 run win but also the series
won nothing sudden yes it is either the
home series was important to us it's
been a long time since the Test series
was played in Pakistan this Test series
were special for each player to win
obviously everyone's overwhelmed
Pakistan's test future still remains
uncertain Bangladesh are scheduled to
visit next but they want their series
move to a neutral venue for now however
Pakistan will celebrate this historic
moment Sohail malik al Jazeera